hey guys in this mkbhd video we're going
to be taking a look at some test footage
of the Canon t2i and 18 to 55 millimeter
kit lens and more importantly taking a
look at the 13-inch laptop you see in
front of you the Asus UL 30 a the true
all-day ultra portable with a 12 hour
battery life so let's take a look the
form factor of this machine is
absolutely phenomenal it is razor thin
it has an LED backlit display and all
the things that contribute to its
battery life are absolutely stacked it
has that LED display it has an Intel X
25 and 40 gig SSD installed by me in it
4 gigs of ddr3 RAM and just a phenomenal
ultra-low voltage Intel processor and
all of that contributed to a 10 to 12
hour daily battery life on the regular
battery on the left side of the notebook
you have your only vent fan which hardly
ever spins followed by a VGA and HDMI
ports for display out and one of your
three USB ports over here you also get a
good idea of the 0.98 inch thickness of
the laptop at its greatest on the
right-hand side to bring into focus the
multimedia card reader the headphone and
microphone jack two of the other three
USB ports Ethernet and your power so in
terms of connectivity on this ultra
portable I think it's just fine it has
built-in Wireless n so there's not
really anything missing and it's really
got everything you need the screen as I
said before is also led not LCD so that
means number one it is razor thin number
two saves a ton of battery life and
number three gets really good color
contrast and representation on the
screen so if you're doing photo work on
this glossy screen even though I have a
matte screen protector on it some people
prefer the glossy screen and that is an
option on this laptop the whole machine
really is a nice elegant and glossy
style except on the back which I'll show
you later so if you're a neat freak like
me and you don't want there to be
fingerprints on it definitely take one
of your electronics microfibers and
dedicate it to this notebook the
trackpad itself is also glossy but one
thing is nice is that they separated
from the rest of the notebook with this
nice these little indentations that are
actually dots and this trackpad is
special also because the drivers it
comes with our multi-touch so you have
two fingered scrolling three fingered
right-click and all sorts of other guest
use that you would be used to on any
other multi-touch device one thing
that's also pretty cool that I
discovered is that when I remove the
stock hard drive and put in the Intel
solid-state drive and reinstall windows
7 I you
the trackball again and it still works
perfectly with the multi-touch and the
two fingered scrolling and everything so
I didn't have to go online to find the
drivers for that or anything which is
really really nice now the one part of
this laptop that's not glossy is the
back of it as you can see here but
that's actually a really sweet brushed
metal finish with the Asus logo carved
into the back with a nice little shiny
shiny embroidery around it also the
front of the laptop is a nice plastic
grippy rubbery kind of material that
allows you to pick it up and open the
front of it quite easily but I like the
brushed metal finish on the back with a
little free hand to go ahead and show
you around this laptop I might as well
mention now that build quality on this
thing is phenomenal the keyboard feels
really solid opening it is well balanced
you don't have to hold it in place to
open it up its overall an extremely
nicely built machine I can't have any
complaints with that this model also has
an ultra-thin
removable battery which is something
that some of its competitors do not have
when Co Inc and it is pretty much nice
you wouldn't actually have to remove it
in most cases but if you get an extended
battery like I did a 12 cell you're
going to be looking at something like 14
to 15 hours of battery life which is
truly all-day computing on the bottom
you also have your screws to access the
RAM and the hard drives which are just a
couple of screws away from accessing
which is how I install the Intel X 25 M
40 gig solid-state drive overall I am
totally satisfied with this laptop
honestly I have zero complaints that has
a built-in webcam and microphone has
three USB ports HDMI and VGA for
connectivity solid build construction
and really awesome quality well-balanced
great keyboard there is nothing bad I
have to say about this notebook which is
rare in my occasion and it's going to
earn the second-ever mkbhd 10 out of 10
rating for a hardware product review so
it's a very impressive notebook and I
would highly recommend it to anyone who
wants something portable with all-day
battery life and just needs something to
have on the go so this has been in my
review of the ace of the UL 30 a go
ahead and leave your feedback on this
video the Canon t2i video quality or
even this laptop in the comment section
below
talk to you later peace
so how many more may say you're a family
an epic of this laptop